This
next
excerpt comes from original tape W sixty six.
Yet
again bellow
my ear tells about. Well. One down I
came down and. Well there's three
guys that came out with these have died down a large two man the eighth and
ninth grade A day later
my charity for her
and
Tierney where we can stand up there and David Rutledge
Well and ran for a life with this. Well they would well
edge to go off out there and also right let's work with them and I want to ask them
as they started. Our Air Force
the Bronx brushing off
and there is this possum just down
the line our train is good and going on a long way. Yes they all day on
day with this crisis like love and they again the cautious baby
didn't look lucky very well we didn't put in the truck the next
morning and when we we did. Well it
was they always will cook it the next day well including the main one is
fraught with the unseen Yes and the little
baby footprints all over that they will have one
for with Carla Dale and then for and get for the family.
We found Cuomo
now turning to the right.
May as well
as a camping trip I really don't know exactly only my
own project you are going to verify your
great grandson more hands. I'm like three
going home I want to hear there's a
down and. He got me mad one time she turned
to my brother him. Well as you're too much for me because he is small and you.
Well knew that
their knees was we all are
brothers here on this song that the numbers are
all one hundred seventy five when you have a string and
retire across rows Maria's down large dark room we
just made nothing while my
wife didn't do nothing to bark but she got me a set
down by a but he
never found any who was NOT know and I'm not going to lead.
But again you think another Drake that you might like them
by yours is
that this minority is called Main to
come right in to look at the Do ye was a listener just what they used
was you can bet he says what he said almost let me tell you what
mine really
says. What I'm doing wrong it's just my neither you call
me REAL out call you a boy.
Why he goes to new.
And you had word from home to a lovely looking
now started taiko for the attack time out issues
the
year under Jesus tieless you best not
to use to shoot together. He started a
company there. Well he is but a man. Yeah
I'll leave him all
right just called not a hater for calling. There those friends.
You heard rumors were flying over a tree come some
by. Well
aware of
the pocketbook trick our viewers like
that park the drape
right well and you are right.
And and your pocketbook and straight there.
Now get some money a little cash to get out
and I mean I wonder how long. Lou number
one I didn't let the
Grinch near this person a comeback. Not get across
the spirit with vision on who could talk lose the chance to start a great war
Apple Iranians more well I can't bump for him to
only Carter come across the piano.
Well how come they don't necessarily live pocketbook came across the meter
I reach for any journalist their money in the
wires right now that. P.S. we're learning and
water everything. I wanted him to do reprogram the
year like watch for.
Hercules one day
as those old cams colonial town movie.
Then you don't want to use that reason might be
programmed you to love their name. There's a
town name and you want
the user
in Iran and the knight trial
one the way it was foolish ready rich my.
Least
honored was then an understanding that three mile
their forty's many
very well he made this water
for everything close
now never had
and
is. Was she is terrified of water and tea
or bottles that read
when I found out where he
is as the ants that
millions of years worth of. The camera thirty days of being
just keep the hell and plus home. All
right well. He started staying there
for months and these are
just three Oh. There's a special on
there in Iraq who are gone car he goes no no.
And we'll come up out of water into
the hell for this little
water for losing their health as to why I'm
so well I have ever put more than one
kiloton else. Well a single can of that water into the hail on to the car
and want to share one turn on what we are and which was of
course when into the current
day itself let alone when I am I got into that little bit in the
summer and you sell them bars are getting in there is there. And they sell this to you.
Well there is those in my home that there is a back in
the home that means best lose jobs and
health for that means that they stay
there and there is a scandal sharks
than blood drives and there is
a compact design and you have to push a button before you
can push the compressor but and she pulls the compressor
over first by the
name. And tractor just so our house in the country
home once they got married and there were a million
to one else. She sure
didn't run out and her husband had to go out there. Do you guys
think and Ted Yoho loves blood and Gator
after tour so was yes well the Sharks won away
but the town by a pool. Well there's a dolphin
playing dolphin let
them let me my morning we're. Well do you
believe will they start chasing
off little sharks and sharks may
have come back you. Well the war was going wrong won't
force through no
last war say a Kansas Navy ship coming
by they start picking up the same home signal from
my house because
her family likes to play rock. I
mean rock nice and not a letter on the garden where like gun
play and an extra big announcing
along on
a regular nice idea of the new kind
of long recess and using that
state will we so far that we have to subpoena
God and man and they just says to his dad or any other thing
there May was a man I and every bomb
Leslie a was a place there and then here comes
that
is that to do with that is inside the has no meaning that is
so strong
a man a man is
so well on says that they is my and
calls for his or say else by even standard they all want to
go.